this guy looked at me and I said the
other guy had searched me
now this hand got a little tighter on my
shoulder
I'm trying to stay calm but I was
freaked
we hit these hard plaques into my arms
he kept going and then he hit these hard
plaques around my waist
and he kept going
Wow I guess he didn't really feel it I'm
the least religious the people but at
that point I'm binding like that please
Jesus get me out of this I will never do
this crap again please
but then it came back up and when it
came back up anything now my heart is
really beating and this guy's looking
right at me I could see in his mind oh
my god wow again he's looking for bombs
he's looking for a terrorist and in his
mind he's got a terrorist took out his
gun stuck at my waist bringing bomb a
bomb above it and all the soldiers put
their rifles down and people started
scurrying around and I'm just frozen
there
my whole life was hanging right in that
moment the reality what was gonna happen
next was beyond me
he realized that's its that's hash
that's the wrong that's wrong Turkish
word - hey she said you know hash it's
hash I like everybody was all God it's
just hash everybody was so relieved
except me of course
it was the changing point in my life
everything in my life was pre and post
that moment at the airport everything
changed and it's literally shaped my
life from that moment till now